this video is sponsored by book Walker
helping burning coal fighters on the
world to transform myself an event I'm
just gonna jump into this one I'm sure
you're now as bored as I am just
wondering why the ISA Kaiser honour is
still as dominant as it is in anime it
feels weird to think that just a few
years ago I'd never even heard of the
word and nowadays are more like c.b.c
fee see in and meet me cha me cha what
were these make-believe genres that
don't exist in anime and hot of the
heels of slimey boy worming its way into
all our hearts we now have the rising of
the shield hero dominating in popularity
both in Japan and here in the West
showing us that Issei Chi is far from
dead and you know I've just come to
accept that you know Issei Chi doesn't
die just reincarnates into another show
but his popularity has got me thinking
about the dominant journey Issei Kai's
taken in this past decade and I wanted
to use this video not only to discuss
what could be appealing about shield
hero to make it as popular as it is but
also how it fits in with the evolution
of the genre so far and what it could
mean for the future the currently Sakai
era was arguably started with the
massive success of sword art online and
has since then dominated anime with a
big show coming out every year or two
and lots and lots and lots of others in
between without strongly the tropes in
cliches have been established in each
Sakai it's easy to forget the John Ray's
existed for far longer than that and it
didn't always have the same trademarks
it does now but one important thing to
know with the recent successful shows is
that they seem to come from a place that
understands the core appeal of modern
Issei Chi and in a sense has taken that
foundation and built on it in a
different way connoisseurs basically a
sitcom set in an essay Kyra Zira sets
about deconstructing the overpowered
otaku protagonist archetype overlord
asks what would happen if we follow the
bad guys slime refines all the tropes
into a wholesome package and that brings
me to shield hero which follows this
evolution the genres taken see one thing
that's definitely changes the general
driving force that moves the plot
early Issei Chi revolved around the idea
of characters trying to get back to
their original worlds but nowadays ISA
Kai's fully embrace the inner self
syrtis gave his fantasy a lot of people
wouldn't have much interest from going
home the overabundance of otaku
protagonists is what lends itself to
making this work the protagonists are
happy to remain in the fantasy world
because why would the hero want to
return to solitude and boredom when
they're living out the rock star
lifestyle the author understands that
this is what the audience would likely
do themselves if presented with such a
world
shield hero takes his self-awareness a
step even further and makes everyone
just non should only accept that they've
been transported to another world
immediately except that they're on some
kind of world saving quest and just know
that this works like a video game
despite the fact that he got sucked into
a book is anyone gonna address that no
all right which was actually weirdly
refreshing to see everyone is so
familiar with this ongoing concept that
we as an audience aren't surprised
anymore and thus having an in-depth
explanation and an air of shock would
just be jarring and dull like you know
the moment in zombie movies when the
undead star appearing and eating people
and the in universe characters are like
Oh what should we call them I know maybe
we'll call them biters cuz ur they bite
and you're they're shouting you say guys
become so prevalent that if tomorrow any
of you got transported to some fantasy
world I guarantee your first reaction
would be wait a minute is this is this
it's like one of my Japanese enemies and
that's basically what's happened here
it's firmly establish a shield here that
he's familiar with the trophy Sakai and
that cuts out so much of the needless
faff at the beginning and just get
straight to the point
non-god Arnold a meet I dunno and that
starting point is that we have four
Issei Chi heroes each from the different
legendary weapon that's been tossed to
save the kingdom from a wave of monsters
that will attack periodically and see
that's how you know the source material
is written in 2013 because it's just II
say Chi horde modes and if it was
actually written recently we just have a
bunch of hero summon for Issei Chi
battle royale which I'm surprised
doesn't exist yet wait a minute he's a
guy at Battle Royale
the gimmick this time is that our
protagonist has a shield so he can only
focus on defense and as far as gimmicks
goes that's pretty standard compared to
the other things we've seen but really
the initial thing that makes shield hero
stand out is how they handle our main
characters starting point now Fumiya the
shield heroes taken out a few pegs in
the first episode and by taking down a
few pegs I mean he tripped over fell
down a flight of stairs found out those
stairs led to an edge of a cliff
plummeted off the cliff into some jagged
rocks got swept away or was drowning in
the ocean before washing up on shore
only then to realize that he never even
got laid
he gets absolutely [ __ ] over and dict
on left right and center and ends up
hated by everyone yeah he quickly does
become powerful but nothing's made easy
for him he isn't this shining Prince
that saves the day and gets adored by
everyone around him he has to work
harder than his peers to make ends meet
and what makes the compelling is that he
isn't always acting morally just he
rightly lashes out and uses underhanded
tactics against the world that hates him
he buys slaves and every so often he'll
act in a certain way that makes you
think see I'm not sure if you're just
being edgy or just being a dick yeah
when push comes to shove he still acts
more heroic than the other heroes and
you do sympathize with the bitterness he
feels from the situation he's been put
in because he starts at such a deficit
it's entirely up to him and his actions
to prove to the people around him what
his true character is and this is the
perfect setup to see a really
satisfactory hero's journey as he rises
up truly winning the hearts of the
people hence the title the rising of the
shield hero and that's the cause for
celebration people it's a light novel
title of a short relevant and a cap
slates what the series is about but I
wouldn't be telling the full story if I
said that seeing now moomies rise is the
only reason everyone's watching this
because I think equally important is the
promise of seeing certain other people
fall like alright I consider myself a
pretty chill and laid-back guy it's hard
to get on my nerves and even if you do
I'm sure we can talk it out and move
past any problem we have I believe the
world would be a much better place if we
could solve our issues in a civilized
manner
they're gonna hope this [ __ ] [ __ ]
dies in a fire your hero is a rare
instance of Nisa Kaiser has an actual
antagonist in it mine and the King make
you question whether this kingdom was
worth saving or burning everything to
the ground and Chad Spears wound is so
frustratingly naive and has that kind of
face only a fist could love sure they
aren't exactly the deepest and most
unique characters out there but they
feel their purpose very well it's been a
while since I've seen characters mothers
brought up genuine anger and frustration
in me halfway through episode 4 I
thought I would actually need to take
some anger management classes or at
least print out to cut out mine and
taper to a punching bag
but as weird as that may sound that's
one of the biggest strengths of the
series these are characters we love to
hate and seeing any kind of victory no
matter how small is extremely satisfying
Marissa I'm not the Hansa coin it's
either
o'kiku Stangl disco Oh to address the
elephant in the room there's been a lot
of controversy around her mind turned
everyone against now for me in the first
place what I will say is that it was a
very quick and effective method in
making you absolutely despise this one
character and establishing the setup for
the show and I don't think it's trying
to do any more than just that so I think
that's pretty much all the main reasons
everyone's watching this it wouldn't be
a proper easter chi without some
seasonal girls to fight over and this
time we of course have the token lolly
character in phyllo she's not a 200 year
old vampire this time though so to be
safe will refer to her by codename thick
chick and what more can i really say
about Roth Talia except I'm considering
starting a cryptocurrency around Rafa
Talia Appel faces because dear God this
is worth pouring my life savings into
anyone want to get in on that no weather
is the alternative [ __ ] coin she does
have this strange crush thing going on
with now for me but it's cute you know
it's not weird at all no matter how
crafty Talia acts towards now for you me
because now free me just sees her as a
daughter and that's completely fine cuz
she could still call him daddy well so I
don't really understand how she
transformed from a cute lolly to grown
woman in the span of a single episode
but you know what it's probably best not
to think about it too deeply I mean you
know it's it's it's anime so they play
by their own rules so I'm just gonna
leave it there it's not worth looking
into so I'm going to do the sensible
thing and just move on
and that's so far what I can say about
why people are being drawn to this show
but as revolutionary as I wished I could
say shield hero is it's really not
because to put it in a nutshell shield
hero is basically what happens when a
character enters the ISA Kai loading
screen and is like what do I want to do
this time I've done that done that front
doing that again I'll just Jubilee it
has a subtle differences but is
essentially the same package we've all
seen before he'll kick some arse impress
some girls everyone's gonna get really
excited to see what happens next and
then we're gonna be waiting for a season
two that's never gonna happen and to me
its immense popularity shows that
despite how saturated si Kai has been
over the years now we still apparently
aren't bored of it yet yes as much as we
complain we're still Issei Kai trash so
the question that comes to mind is
what's going to be next if we think of
the modern roofs of the genre of 90s si
Kai and stuff like escaflowne being the
first generation and the big breakout
hit setting the trend on fire like Sao
being the second then what I found is
all these big si Kai from these past
years would be the third and current
generation re0 Overlord no game no life
cannot see burst slime shield hero every
single one of these bigger shows were
familiar with began publishing as light
novels around 2012 and 2013 hot off the
heels of Si OS adaptation blowing up the
community they are Issei Kai that have
essentially been inspired by Issei kind
have each taken their own spin on the
genre well very much daring to the core
foundations that were laid out some
satirized and subverted tropes some
refined the tropes and some were a
mixture of the two if there is gonna be
a fourth generation of Issei Kai anime
from some of the newer light novels I've
seen floating around concepts are gonna
get even [ __ ] weirder if we look
further for this year there's gonna be
ISA Kai scattered in every season and if
we look at the light novel world the
genre still completely dominates new
titles coming out so however you look at
it I think the message is loud and clear
ISA Kai is here to stay and right now
it's still stronger than ever to a much
lesser extent this almost feels like
what happened with comic book movies and
Hollywood I remember when the Dark
Knight came out there was a consensus
that this was
the peak of comic book movies and
audiences were going to slowly start to
lose interest because of how saturated
the genre had become and just as that
happens Marvel came along and I don't
think I need to tell you what happens
next so as long as it's here to stay
let's just all embrace the east like I
trash within us because even though it's
overwhelming right now if you're bored
of it there are plenty of other genres
you can watch in anime because not
everything is a nice a car why would you
do this why no one asked you can can you
just go away and you know what I'm gonna
let it slide this one time but can we
just please stop doing this hey guys
hope you enjoyed that thank you to book
Walker for officially sponsoring this
video you can read ahead in the manga or
light novel and shield hero on book
walker in the link below I know this is
a bit sudden but the first volume is
available for absolutely free right now
but you only have about two days to
claim that so if you want that go get it
right now or if you just want to find
out all the spicy things that I'll go to
happen click the link below and get
reading also every si Kai I mentioned in
this video from sio2 rezero ii cannot
see but overlord is also available on
their platform so if you want to further
your si Chi fix and you're a new user
you can use coupon code to get for $5
off which basically means you get
another volume for hardly anything
anyway that's it for me though I've been
gig ugh and I'll see you all next time